so this was huh this was a Kodama the
Slavic folklore group in Belgium
accompanied by Thomas cook Elisha play
the iconic song angel by Carol Carol the
choreography that was prepared specially
for this location used two steps and
rhythms of the traditional Slavic dance
from the region of Horomia a symbolic
reminder of the power of the people and
routes who came together to the streets
and squares to fight for the democracy
and freedom in 99
so together with the photographs from
this period we tried to create an
authentic atmosphere of those
revolutionary days so thank you again
ladies and gentlemen as you know Veeam
we have met here tonight to inaugurate
the exhibition 1989 The Velvet
Revolution the event was prepared in the
collaboration of the vice president of
the European Commission mr. Marshall
Kovac member of the european commission
madame de rio roba permanent
representation of the czech republic to
the european union permanent
representation of the slovak republic to
the universe began in yin and the czech
central Brussels and now the time is for
the opening speeches so let me please
invite all the speakers here with me to
the stage
[Applause]
so let me present to you now the
vice-president of the European
Commission mr. Marshall Chavez for the
first opening remarks thank you very
much good evening to all of you it's
really very symbolic and hard forming to
have the possibility to really mark this
very special occasion for all of us here
in Berlin and I really would like to
welcome in particular my colleague not
only the Commissioner about
vice-president basicnet Vieira
Urawa with whom we've been really the
best bodies in the current European
Commission but also my colleague
Commissioner still Ian eNOS who is also
man of great knowledge personal warm and
great charm and I'm very much
appreciating the fact that you are here
but of course two of my close colleagues
and friends Miroslav wide shock not only
and the Foreign Minister Slovakia but my
friend of many years and ambassador of
Czech Republic mr. doar with whom we
also have a lot of a lot of common
stories and if I'm looking in the
audience I see my friends members of the
European Parliament I see my first boss
here from the Federal Foreign Minister
mr. kovanda and I and I see a lot of
friends and colleagues from the time of
the of the Velvet Revolution and I know
them all because this was the moment
which we very often discussed together
because I think definitely for me this
was the few weeks and month which
forever will be stuck in my memories is
probably the most important period for
our generation and therefore I am so
happy that together with my friends and
colleagues we can open this exhibition
of iconic photographs because you know
it very well the photograph is very
often worth
of thousand words and I'm sure that the
photographs will very clearly do the
merit to the saying and it will simply
see how dramatic the information that
the the situation was what was the
tension in the faces of the people and
how not everyone was hundred percent
sure that everything will work out fine
what happened in the Velvet Revolution
was the fact that after four decades we
in Central and Eastern Europe could
finally enjoy the same freedom which
which way in which were taken for
granted in Western European countries
freedom of expression freedom of
assembly freedom of speech and freedom
of travel for all those born after 1989
for example my children it's totally
incomprehensible when I was describing
to them that we have actually the Iron
Curtain that fence just few kilometers
from our apartment and for us to cross
the river Danube and go to Austria was
something of unthinkable dream when we
look at Europe today we know how much
has changed and how much we have
accomplished I have to say and now I
believe that I can also speak a little
bit for our Czech friends then together
Czechs and Slovak we accomplished a lot
since well with revolution - 15 years of
very hard work we joined the European
Union we join the key military alliance
NATO and we can testify all of us that
it was not a smooth process but that we
have to earn it we have to reform we
have to transform and we had to deliver
and we really did it and therefore our
both countries are today very important
members of the European Union I would
like to conclude on the fact that also
today 30 years how to fall of Berlin
Wall after the Velvet Revolution that we
have to appreciate the freedom and we
cannot take it for granted because
freedom is something you have to work
for every single day and this is what
the European Union's tent forts and this
is what all of us are working hard to
deliver on
to conclude I just would like to make
two references one to Alexander Dubcek
who wanted to bring as a Slovak leader
of the Prague Spring the human face into
the politics but also to vaclav havel
who I believe managed to bring humanism
to the daily political and decision
making so thank you very much to all of
you for coming over here to celebrate
this very important moment in our
history with us I'd like to thank my
colleagues for making this exhibition
possible and I'm sure you will enjoy the
photographs and the talk and bit of the
memories we are very happy to share with
all of you of such an important moment
in our history thank you very much thank
you very much good evening WH er it's a
great pleasure and honor for me to be
with you tonight and thank you all for
joining us to remember these fascinating
days of November 1989 in Bratislava in
Prague and all over the former
Czechoslovakia and we know that our
revolution was held under two slogans
the first one was free elections and the
second one was returned to Europe and it
was the call of Europe the community
that cherishes democratic values that
protects the rights and improves lives
of people that we wanted to belong to
and we accomplished our dreams 15 years
later when we joined European Union and
this was the moment when finally the
walls and barriers that started falling
down in 1989 were finally removed today
30 years later I'm glad to say that
Slovakia and the Czech Republic reminds
the closest allies and partners sharing
not only the common past but also the
common vision for the future and we are
proudly offering and hosting this
exhibition for you and I also want to
say that even today 30 years after our
revolution it still has a lot to offer
too many let me mention three points
first it's non violent nature namely the
fact you know it was not called Velvet
Revolution by chance and it proved that
democracy can be born without arms and
without violence second the way it
unified the nations and what started as
an initiative of some very quickly turn
into a event in into a movement support
by almost everyone and it shows how much
we can achieve if we want together and
how far we can go if we work together
for common good and thirdly the call of
Europe it was Europe that mobilised us
it was Europe that inspired us and
Europe still continues to inspire
millions of people outside of the
borders of the European Union and let us
not forget these people they are still
Europeans finally they say a picture is
worth a thousand words so I would like
to invite you all to enjoy this
exhibition it brings the story the
emotions the hopes of those fascinating
days and I hope it can still inspire you
thank you very much
thank your excellency the minister of
the Foreign Affairs of the Czech
Republic could not join us tonight he is
sending his warmest regards but I do
have the honor to welcome here tonight
the Ambassador the permanent
representative of the Czech Republic to
the European Union his Excellency a
50-year thank you it good evening
WH era the reason why the minister
couldn't be here he is actually at the
pilgrimage to the Vatican to actually
celebrate 30 years of a major event
which started the Velvet Revolution in
Czechoslovakia and this is the patron
Agnes who was actually starting the
events in Czechoslovakia vieira marish
miss Lloyd Chuck excellencies guests
it's a great honor to be here and to
have the opportunity to tell you how
great we are how grateful we are for the
way we can celebrate 30 years after this
content and rebellion fight for freedom
and democracy 30 years ago we saw a
turning point between talk and action
and that was Czechoslovak contribution
to the world
we brought the name the term Velvet
Revolution to the existence no single
bullet was shot and that was unheard of
unimaginable when you would also imagine
that the evil of empire the the empire
which wasn't collapsing so easily was
still there and without any drop any any
blood being shed that is what was
happening The Velvet Revolution or
sometimes Slovaks and others call it
gentle revolution was later applied as a
tremor to describe the revolutions in
Poland Hungary East Germany
over the course of all those all those
years and months 30 years on what
happened in Europe in 1989 became a
model for other nonviolent pro-democracy
movements which have triumphed in many
countries since then tamati Gordon - the
liberal thinker and essayist and a
scholar in his very famous book year of
miracles who described it in a very
clear dynamics as it happened what took
polls ten years it took hungarians ten
months it took Eastern Germans ten weeks
and in a way it took czechoslovaks ten
days the symbol of demonstrations
besides massive Havel and Alexander
checked both were mentioned by previous
speakers
it was a cleaning lady it was a cleaning
lady who was prohibited any public
appearance or performance and suddenly
she occurred on the balcony on the Venza
square and now she is singing the most
famous song of 1968 the prayer for
Martin it was actually the Czech
humanist and philosopher who gave her
the lyrics Comenius the teacher of the
nations let me quote these are the words
of the song which became one of the
symbols of the revolution
besides the angel the second one let
peace remain with this country
Meli's and we spite fear and strife let
those parts let them quickly finally
pass away now that you're lost
governance of your affairs is returning
to you people is returning the cloud is
slowly flowing away from the sky and
everybody is harvesting what Dave song
but my prayer speak to the hearts which
by the time of hire
we're not burnt like flowers by frost
like by frost those words were used by
Vassar Havel in his first presidential
speech on 1st of January 1990 and I know
that Vassar Havel is an inspiration to
all of us and I understand why in the
speech he gave to the European
Parliament in Strasbourg in March 1994
he said this referring to the European
Union if the citizens of Europe
understand that this is not just an
anonymous bureaucratic monster to limit
or even deny their autonomy but simply a
new type of human community that
actually broadens their freedoms
significantly then the European Union
need not to fear for its future the task
is convincing our citizens that it is
indeed what Europe is about it is still
relevant as ever and I think that we all
could get it here today need to embody
the essence of this endeavor as human
rather than anonymous or bureaucratic
today we are far from being perfect we
face problems but of different nature
than before most importantly we do not
face them alone but together in our
European family it is a testimony to the
European nature of the anniversary that
we are celebrating it in a prominent
company of the two European
commissioners in the seats of the
European Commission with a crowd of
Czechs Slovaks and internationals we
learned many lessons in 1989 we need to
remember those lessons not in nostalgia
not in celebrating freedom or not in
fighting only for the Fremen as it was
130 years ago but in our relations with
countries that are currently unfree it
was our mistake to imagine that a
revolution creates a perfect government
and society a new normal irreversible
progress
this is not the case I'm afraid ladies
and gentlemen The Velvet Revolution it
seems has not just a past but also a
present and a future a model for now how
the voice of the people can be heard
thank you
Thank You ambassador and finally let me
also welcome for the opening remarks the
hosts of this event tonight
go machine madame vaviiova
[Applause]
excellencies ladies and gentlemen dear
colleagues dear friends let us celebrate
today because there is a very strong
case very strong reason for celebration
well it's imaginable 30 years I remember
very well the Velvet Revolution we were
so young so fresh so energetic now we
are fresh and energetic but still I
remember the total happiness and a foria
finally we got rid of Bolsheviks and a
year before Velvet Revolution we we did
not even think about that it might one
day come and then the Germans the
Germans started to move and in Hungary
in Poland everything was suddenly moving
and waiting for the Czechs and Slovaks
to move again you are still young
energetic and fresh Mirage
don't worry it didn't I didn't apply to
you well so we have a very good reason
to celebrate
because Velvet Revolution gave us a
fantastic chance it gave us an
opportunity to work for freedom and of
course to pay the price for freedom and
we did it Czechs and Slovaks worked very
hard to have more prosperous and happier
country and perhaps today if what Slava
Havel has a speech I would wish him to
be here with us believe me he would
maybe say our country is flourishing but
I think he would add economically
flourishing and it's not the same thing
the Czechs know what I speak about
because in one of his famous speeches he
mentioned in 1990
Jakub you quoted him from this speech
this country is not flourishing he was
absolutely right so it was a great
success and not only the Velvet
Revolution and the fact that we got rid
of totalitarian regime we joined NATO
and we joined European Union so just let
us imagine where we would be without
that I in fact don't want to imagine it
one of the satellites of Soviet Union
let's forget it
but let's not let's not lose the ability
to imagine it because I think it's very
important answer today I watched the
events in Berlin very carefully I was
looking after my two months old
granddaughter believe me it was
incredible moment she stopped crying
when Angela Merkel started to speak and
I realized wallah this young lady has a
good political instinct and I so I
remember well what Angela Merkel said
that there is not such a big war which
is impossible to destroy but many of us
have to add that the most difficult
thing is to destroy the mental walls
which we have which we still have it was
not easy to get rid of Bolsheviks but
it's much less easy to get rid of
Bolshevik thinking and we still have to
bear this in mind
as I said the czechs and slovaks worked
very hard to live in free and prosperous
country and the Europeans helped us a
lot so that's why I am so happy that I
see many colleagues and friends who are
not Czechs and Slovaks you who come from
other countries because you were helping
us to join the EU I myself in the 90s
went to several study visits to United
Kingdom to France to the Netherlands and
the colleagues in these countries were
not only inviting us they were welcoming
us they wanted us to join the EU and to
to cooperate and it has to be reminded
and we should thank our European friends
for inviting and welcoming us yet there
are not only positive things when I look
at this picture behind our when you look
at the faces I wonder if there is such a
demonstration today whether all of them
would say the Velvet Revolution brought
only positive things
there are many disappointed people the
people on the picture had a dream but
now the people know the reality and
these disappointed people they are
waiting for us to take lessons and to
stop making mistakes I think it was not
planned that in Europe we will have
winners and losers there are too many
people who think they are losers and who
were not able to come along with quick
changes and who feel the frustration of
course when I remember the 90s in the
Czech Republic there was increasing
inequality in the society and many
people work hard to be richer than
others but some not and they were
Richard
automatically because we had some
strange doctrine that no money smells
and that the economy must go first and
then the law and it went to the
detriment of the whole society so still
now we have the people who think that
the revolutions in 1989 were not
successful that they didn't work well
for them and so here I come to our hot
presence there are frustrations which
have the potential to install again
authoritarian regimes I'm so unhappy to
say that and I am also very nervous this
is my sleepless night idea that this
process which we experienced after 1989
may not be irreversible and that we have
to work hard to keep democracy and
Freedoms and as Mirage said I am the
vice president designate for values and
transparency
it is my I am quite nervous about this
fact that freedom and democracy is not
irreversible because we have to work
together for the values I receive a lot
of mails from Czech people when I go to
the Czech restaurant the people come to
me and ask me what are the values you
will work on what is it but there is one
interesting thing Czechs are very ironic
people sometimes very cynical also but
they ask me what do you mean by values
and there is always edit we would like
you to explain that but we feel that it
is something very important and I am
happy about this and
these discussions because it is clear
that we have to explain which merit
values we have in mind and that we must
not be alone with it if you remember
Molossia cash bond around a check this
is another cheque story he said he was
the general secretary of the communist
party and he had a very yes energetic
speech and he said we must not be alone
with our politics I would not expect
myself to quote mr. Kesh today but I
must say we must not be alone with our
politics of protecting values because we
will need the people to be with us what
are the values citizenship active
citizens active citizens which is
something uncomfortable for those who
would like to have outer Praetorian
power independent justice again
something very uncomfortable independent
and pluralistic media again for those
who want to have absolute power in the
society it's uncomfortable so me as the
future vice president responsible for
values I declare here I will be
uncomfortable very much in case of need
so ladies and gentlemen I didn't believe
I will speak longer than than my
predecessors but I'm afraid it's it's
true so let's work hard
let's take lessons but today let's
celebrate and let me finally thank
Anushka Gabriela and
not for organizing this fantastic event
enjoy your evening thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you